e
all right it's uh it's
1:00 uh with that we should uh convene
the division 3 hearing uh we're looking
at a revised schedule today um at at
1:00 we're going to hear
hp71 uh at 2:00 uh uh we will have the
uh commissioner overview um and the
Budget Trailer I is is I think available
uh there's not a lot to it there's like
five pages maybe 12 items um so we ought
to be able to get through that uh for
hp71 Mr
Ripple I want to take the non gerain
amendment that we discussed with
519 and I want to at the end of the day
do something with it uh can are we
allowed to discuss it today because I
don't see it on the calendar and I I I
was I I I we have discussed it in public
right so I guess so I guess for
clarification do you want to add dis
discuss the
amendment that you'd previously
recommended for 519 or the slightly
different amendment that you had for 71
it's barely different the only
differences are that it fits and now
makes it fit with 71 okay
um all I know is that I had a an email
conversation with the clerk after after
our last meeting and he thought before
you voted on it um since it's being
attached to a different bill it would
require a new public hearing on a
non-main Amendment um I don't think that
precludes you from discussing anything
today well I maybe we could just go
ahead and make a division recommendation
on it and have the uh full finance
committee properly noticed so that when
our recommendation goes to full Finance
it can be heard then okay Mr chairman
yes ma'am I'm sorry to to dispute
process here but I would be very
uncomfortable to vote on an amendment
and division when there requires a
public hearing I feel that that does not
give respect to the public that needs to
um come out and speak to the effect of
the amendment and and I violently agree
with you which is why the public hearing
will be in front of the full finance
committee which respects it even more
because there'll be more of us available
correct so I don't believe that as a
division we should discuss it or take a
vote a division vote today which I
thought I just heard you say we would do
I I hear you and I I'm leaning towards
taking a vote and you can vote the way
you
want I would object on the process there
all right all right Mr chairman yes a
point of clarification what are we uh
voting on the amendment itself I'll get
to it okay thank you I I'm I was working
out with with Mr Ripple what what what
what what what what is in play and what
is not and so I I'm I'm ready to make a
motion to um move uh OTP on House Bill
71 FN uh with an amendment to be
discussed is there a
second I'll second that okay uh seconded
all right so I think we're supposed to
discuss the amendment
first um this was the amendment that
we've already discussed that was going
to be part of
519 uh nothing material has changed from
519 uh so we we have discussed and it
was uh did already have a public Hearing
in uh that
context um and in that meeting we said
that uh we would be trying to attach it
to 71 out of respect for
519 and so uh with get that uh in place
what the amendment does is exactly what
we said it would do um it uh it tells
the
department that for contracts all of
their contracts or addenda should
include a provision requiring the
contractor to comply with the patient
Bill of Rights pursuant to RSA 151 colon
21 it sets up a repeal same as the other
one uh relative to DH HS contracts um
will will uh will repeal wait a second
section okay and so it sets up a repeal
so that this requirement expires
November 30th
2026 I want to require to get it into
the law but I don't want to keep the law
hanging around forever uh because it
should at some point just become
practice and then because we're sticking
it in
71 71
uh needed to have its effective date uh
changed and it stays the same line 17
the remainder of this act shall take
effect 60 days after its passage which
is what is said on line 20 of the bill
so
um so that is the amendment
representative tersi I just wanted to go
back to what we discussed last week
which is I believe we all agreed that
this amendment as drafted um met our
needs yes to the First non- gerain
Amendment so we all felt really felt
good with this however we I have written
here on the top that we need the non-
derain amendment full hearing that needs
to be
scheduled in order to then attach it to
71 so I guess I am just confused I
thought today we were coming to discuss
House Bill 71 so so we are discussing 71
the be the underlying uh uh motion was
to uh move 71 as an OTP and with an a
with an amendment and this is the
amendment we're discussing yeah can can
you tell me substantially what's
different now remember I'm doing this
for you guys I app I could have stuck
this on to 519 and ignored I 100% am
saying that I AG could use a little bit
of leeway now just to get this off of
our plate
I'm just clarifying that we can't get
this off of our plate until we have a
non-gain hearing on this amendment okay
I understood the work session today was
to talk about the underlying bill that's
why I'm confused and trying to clarify
the point of this meeting that was
scheduled at 1 p.m do you do you see any
substant substantive difference between
uh the amendment as proposed today on
0416 hotel and what we had last week
week that uh I had intended to attach to
519 you see anything substantively
different yes yes represent wner go
ahead I don't see anything different
about it my only question
is what if just what if someone showed
up at the non-main amendment
hearing with some sort of new
information and that and here we have
already acted
on the non-main amendment before we've
had the hearing and that I think is what
confusing I think we have a calendaring
issue I wish it would have been on
today's calendar um but uh I didn't make
sure that that happened I think we can
fix it by saying that there'll be a non
gerine Amendment hearing on the next
full Finance are we meeting tomorrow yes
but but it's too late to put the
non-main amendment tomorrow also right
well the division is meeting tomorrow
but the non-gain amendment hearing would
be before the full committee which and
as far as I know the full committee
doesn't have a uh an upcoming meeting
scheduled so so can we add it to the
next and today we're just making a
recommendation the non gerain Amendment
hearing can be done done
on the F First full finance committee my
my plan was to schedule it for the next
meeting of the full finance committee
yes
yeah okay we'll we'll I think we can do
that and then uh I want to change my uh
uh motion on
hp71 and uh I vote I would like to move
to retain it
until after we get the non gerain
Amendment heard and because I want to
attach it to 71 so I don't I don't think
I can move 71 today because it won't be
around to stick the non gerain Amendment
on later is that
right this is just a work session I
believe Mr chairman I know to discuss
base the base bill of 71 about that the
content of it and the fiscal note on the
base bill of 71 because we had questions
last
week you you had questions on 71 yeah
yeah we'll come back to 71 I'm I'm just
trying to uh figure out how to get these
two uh put together I don't believe we
have to take any official action today
as a division on the bill or the
amendment is what I'm the the thing I
want to see happen is I want to see us
get to the floor uh at some point as
quickly as possible with 71 with an
otpa of of this
uh previously known your main amendment
I want to do an otpa on 71 with this
amendment that's where I want to end
up correct okay
so so I don't know that we can do
anything more today on the non gerain
Amendment other than to schedule it for
the First full full finance committee is
that correct that's correct okay so so
today I think that would likely be the
recommendation of the clerk all right so
so I'm going to withdraw my Amendment uh
that means the second needs to be
[Music]
withdrawn I'll withdraw the second okay
so so now we need a new motion on uh on
71 and I since I don't want to see this
voted on I want it to discussed today so
that we can have it available to attach
the amendment to later so so so what
would be the proper motion for
that I I don't think you need a motion
uh this being a work session you could
just discuss whatever aspects of the
bill you want to very good so we're
we're going to go into a work session on
House Bill 71 FN do you have a question
that was it that was my clarification
that this is just a work session and we
can jump right in there's no vote today
this is just a work
session
Stringham Stringham I I appreciate and
understand everything you're saying I
say it's not necessary for division 3 to
ever uh speak out on hp71 and still have
the bill whether amended or not amended
emerg from Finance it can go directly to
finance without uh having having had us
uh act on it but you can decide or we
whe whether we need to after the
non-gain amendment is introduced
whatever it is whether we have to meet
as uh division three and make a make a
vote but it could go straight to finance
for final vote my understanding of the
process okay I'll I'll we'll have time
I'll have time to to figure that out
with the clerk and all um but I
appreciate your uh input I think we'll
be okay if we schedule the amendment for
the to be heard in full finance and if
we don't send 71 to full Finance yet
then we can come back to a subsequent
division three and make a recommendation
then so in the second full finance
committee there'll be a properly formed
motion representative priest did you
also have a question no who I did but
it's uh been resolved thank you
representative walner did you have a
question represent lurki question I'm
just looking at my notes from last week
and the questions we had last week
that's it all right so um is there
chairman Edwards for the record my name
is John Williams I'm the legislative
director for Health Human Services and I
brought with me uh somebody who will be
able to help answering some of the
questions that I was not able to answer
at last week's work session all right
thank you welcome can can we make sure
the clerk has your name absolutely I'm
Jenny O Higgins I'm a legislative
liaison for Behavioral Health at
DHHS now am I right to assume that you
were the one primarily providing input
to the LBA on the fiscal note yes that's
right oh super super are there questions
oh oh Higgins or Higgins oh Higgins oh
Higgins okay are there questions for m o
Higgins representative
priest yes thank you Mr chairman for
taking my question and thank you for
being here um my question is it's my
understanding that we would be losing or
potentially losing
8.5 I'm sorry 12 to18 million a year if
this bill is passed is that correct so
the our our fiscal analysis was based on
the term used within the bill that said
specified alien where we could not find
a direct definition but when we looked
into the definition of specified alien
in the um act it with included in the
bill it referred to any person who's a
non- US Citizen and So based on that
including all non- US citizens we
included both our HUD funding and our
office of refugee resettlement funding
that could be potentially affected by
that definition and so we have been able
to pull exactly what we have for our
actuals from 24 as well as our project
projected budget and that's why that
range and where that comes from follow
up thank you Mr chairman and thank you
for taking this followup is this a
problem now in in local communities are
is are our local schools being flooded
by immigrants and people asking for
Asylum that you know about we have no
time other questions represent
Daniels thank you i' like to take a
definition one step further you've
identified an alien as a non- US citizen
could you identify what an
alien who has not been admitted into the
United States is so it was not clear in
our analysis of this definition to that
our understanding we had to use just the
term alien because that's what was in
definition that's referred to within the
bill um let me just reference
back that you
just did this over to me right I have
too many
thank you okay so where it says
specified alien within House Bill 71 is
the immigration and nationality act um
in in section
111a and so I when we look up that
definition there's a definition under
alien but I did not see a definition
under specified alien and so that is why
we uh interpreted it more broadly to
that where it says alien within that
section refers to any person who is not
so if we have misanalyzed that we can
then do a different fiscal analysis but
that was our what we're basing that our
assumptions
on would you agree that there's a
difference between an alien who has been
admitted to the us and one who has not
been admitted to the us correct and so
that's why this could potentially
prohibit the use of shelters um for
those who who have been admitted to the
US and
including the refugees and so when we
looked at those populations the policy
could create some disparities in the
treatment of refugees which um would be
would be problematic and those who have
that are considered non US citizens but
legally U represent seaworth thank you
very much Mr chairman I
like to
get understand this in a little more
detail if I understand what you just
said you're concerned about the
definition in this bill and potential
conflicts with the with the federal law
and you believe that that conflict might
cause you to lose the
money um and I'm I'm trying to
understand the mechanism for that is it
because the de is it because of the
mismatch in definitions or that you are
concerned that when you interpret this
definition you'll do it wrong and
therefore the federal government will
take action under federal law I it
because of the mismatch because it feels
like as though without the list of sort
of what is specified or a clearer
definition of what is specified then we
um are interpreting it more broadly and
then it would include refugees which is
that $3 to8 million range and then also
include potential HUD funding as well so
with the
um with excluding certain groups that
are not undocumented not here
undocumented including those that are
eligible for the office of refugee
resettlement populations the policy
could create some disparities in the
treatment of refugees and that may make
that funding be at risk and and I guess
I'm again I'm trying to get a just a
so excluded from what the fact that you
can't put that person into a school is
what will cause that money to
disappear and and that's why we use the
word may we do not know that it would
but it would go against the intent of
the of the
funding to not be able to shelter folks
that are here documented and then part
of the refugee program would put at risk
the intent of that funding the those it
includes people that are fleeing more in
violence and the intent of the funding
is to is to create safety and so not
allowing a uh Sheltering of those folks
could potentially put a risk that
funding
and again keep going thank you and
specifically in the federal language the
schools are this is specific to schools
in the federal language no this is
General yes the federal language that I
was referencing is within House Bill 71
that they did not find a definition of
specified
alien do you have other questions I got
a question
have have we ever have anywhere in the
United States has the federal government
directed
Sheltering in um a public school
chartered public school public Academy
or institution of Higher Learning have
we has the federal government ever
directed directed that those types of
facilities be used as shelter I don't
have the answer to that question I
imagine in cases of disaster that they
have but I'm not sure so let's assume no
because we have to assume something here
and and so wouldn't it be true that as
long as we found adequate shelter to
support a refugee
request that it wouldn't interfere with
this money if we chose not to use our
schools if we found Alterna ative
adequate shelters we would still comply
with the order and we'd still be
eligible for the money would we not I
think we just don't know if there's a
need or a mandate or that necessitates
the need to open school facilities so
we're because it has not been an issue
in the past we don't have an example to
point to and and looking into the
foreseeable future over the next four
years do you imagine the federal
government directing any refugees be
housed in a public school chartered
public school public Academy or
institution of Higher Learning could do
you do you even imagine that to be a
realistic possibility I I would not make
an assumption about what happen I know
that's not for you as much as it is for
us so um all are there other are there
other questions representative
Stringham uh are there times in the case
of an uh natural disaster that uh the
least expensive uh location might be
uh a public education institution and if
that that was uh not available that you
would have to use something that would
cost us and hence the federal government
more money on your existing
contracts potentially our our regional
public health networks have emergency
preparedness plans that do include
school buildings so if they're not
available that might change the cost of
what it is how did uh if followup would
be how how did you come up with 12 to 18
million as the is that the size of the
current contracts that you have with HUD
and and the um uh office of ref Refugee
resettlement that represent 100% of
those contracts yes so we just utilized
our existing funding from these two
sources that we thought could
potentially be impacted and we did pull
um those accounting units for you all
for today well thank
you represent
Tori thank you thank you for taking my
question um I'm not sure if you're the
person to answer this but I'm going to
put out the question that we had last
week which was what in what does the
term institution facilities
mean do we know I do not know okay um
and a follow-up to that would be um if
this if you believe that this as written
applies to um private institutions of
Higher Learning also say St angelum
College Riv College in nasua or is it
just public higher institutions of
learning and I guess by extension I
could say how about private schools in
um the state could they
shelter as I read it I interpret the the
final you know section there it says
institution of Higher Learning or
facilities of a schools or institution
which is very broad there is
specifically public and public charter
and public Academy me but that secondary
language is Broad and it does not say
public on Higher Learning that's what I
thought thank you very much for
that are are there other
questions thank you thank you for coming
so so I guess I I have another it this
sort of uh jumps out at me is it's it
the last sentences and I know LBA wrote
this but I think they did this on input
in the worst case scenario in which all
such funding were withheld the
department estimates the loss of federal
revenue well aren't there others oh
she's gone Miss Higgins Miss Higgins oh
Higgins I'm sorry I I I I changed my
mind as you were walking from the table
so so I maybe maybe you uh had some
insight on this worst case scenario
language in the final sentence of the
fiscal
note it says in the worst case scenario
in which all such funding were withheld
the department estimates the loss of
federal revenue at 12 to 18 million per
year so so that documents the worst case
scenario did the department have an
opinion on what the most likely scenario
is and and what the best case scenario
is I I mean I really just hate operating
off of a a single worst case scenario as
though dysfunction is is
inevitable U no I thank you for your
question I I think what we did was in
order to because this is not something
that we've had happen before in order to
give you a sense of where it could
potentially impact we simply pulled the
full funding of those two funding
sources from the office of refugee
resettlement and the HUD funding so
you're only looking at that total with
potential supplemental we don't have a
sense of if of impact it was a May would
it be reasonable for us as a committee
you think to be thinking that they're
probably is also a best case scenario
and a most probable scenario that aren't
that isn't written into the fiscal note
potentially I think we're we are not
saying that this will be a loss
absolutely or that this is a direct
impact but just that that it could
potentially go against the intent of
those two pieces of funding we do not we
have a requirement federally on our fud
on our HUD funding the um Housing and
Urban Development funding source the
requirement H is to to shelter with no
precondition and no barrier and so we
that you know and then the office of
refugee resettlement funding has
specific conditions as well um that make
sure to just keep people safe and So
based on the language in those two
pieces we thought there could be
potential impact and again we gave you
the full amount not saying that all of
that would be at risk but that these are
the funding sources that this bill could
potentially impact right when when they
say Sheltering with no barrier does does
does does that mean that people could be
directed to shelter in their own home to
to have refugees sent into private homes
it it doesn't right there there there
are barriers to what shelters we select
what what what constitutes a violation
of the of the of the the thought that we
should not have barriers to shelters so
there is typically in this instance
there there are certain barrier there
are certain things that are considered
barriers by Hud and in this instance the
HUD funding typically prioritizes US
citizens and and eligible non-citizens
and there are Provisions for some
noncitizens particularly those with Leal
legal status so that includes refugees
or lawful permanent residents that
they're able to access um housing
assistance and shelter and so these
individuals who are lawfully present in
the United States such as green card
holders
um those seeking Asylum and certain
other categories of individual with of
individuals with immigration status
recognized by the US government and so
the in the again it's in the
interpretation of the definition of of
alien it goes back to that again because
there are these categories that are
outside of um US citizen that are still
lawfully present and that if we were
impacting those lawfully present that
are not US citizens that would be the
potential conflict with the intent of
the funding sources sure I but I think I
just heard you in in that to to to say
that it would be permissible if there
was a natural disaster kind of thing and
we had to shelter us residents New
Hampshire residents if we had some sort
of a priority for limited shelter space
and we gave first priority to New
Hampshire residents that we could give
secondary or third priority to people in
I hear you and I'm not disagreeing I
validate that but I also believe that in
terms of disaster we often don't have
identification so we we don't it's just
not how we operate emergency shelter is
to look for um people's status it's just
to keep people safe because in terms of
disaster many of us may leave our home
in you know fires or floods or whatever
without identification and so
prioritizing like that could potentially
put any or all of us at
risk okay any new questions
representative stringam it sounds like U
as a possible uh remedy to the passage
of this bill you may have to rework your
emergency uh preparedness program uh
since the um uh essentially schools
would no longer be an appropriate place
for these for anybody because you don't
know that everybody meets the standards
set by the state of New Hampshire um I
assume there would be a cost to revising
the preparedness plans to exclude
schools and that there may be some
impact on on the preparedness plan to be
effective uh you know should a
circumstance uh like a natural disaster
emerge that that that's being done do
you think that's a reasonable response
to this bill um and um uh as WR and um
uh to to uh make sure that you can
comply and not lose these contracts so I
honestly feel like I would have to ask
our colleagues in public health that
oversee emergency preparedness that
question as we are a large department
and I'm from behavioral he so I do feel
like it's a reasonable question but I
don't feel like I'm the right person to
answer
it are there other questions represented
Daniels thank you you you mentioned that
specified alien uh can mean in part
those lawfully present would would they
also include those unlawfully
present the whole analysis is really
based on the fact that there isn't a
definition of specified alien so I think
I'm sorry you said there is not a
definition right I could not find a
definition of specified alien so we did
this analysis based on the definition of
alien so if there's a definition of
specified alien which is
different then we could look at that
separately the B seems to indicate that
there is a definition who has been
admitted as so defined going back to the
whole federal statute correct and when I
looked in the federal statute I did not
locate specified alien only the
definition of
alien if someone else has seen that
specified alien definition and would
provide it to us that could have been my
misstep but I did the analysis based on
um the best information that I could
find and the definition was of the word
alien
so I'm sorry are so you're saying that
if we were to look at section 101a of
the immigration nationality act section
[Music]
1101a that the those things don't exist
those references don't exist or the or
at the reference we still don't have a
definition specified alien the
definition is of alien and then I don't
know if the term specified means
something else within there I just there
wasn't a way so alien is defined in
those sections correct so the analysis
is based on the the definition of alien
within that
National I'm sorry I'm just being
slow all right representative um
seaworth thank you Mr chairman so
again I don't know the background on
this so what I see here is line 11 we've
defined at the state level a new term it
means something for the state specified
alien and is this normal that it if we
try to use terms that aren't defined in
the same way by the federal government
we can't we can't have our own
definitions is that kind of the
background to this no I believe we can
we can have our own definition we we
would have to still be in line with
federal law but we can Define it okay I
think I think we're going to have to get
the bill sponsor in here because I think
what they tried to do was Define alien
but then to say this specified part is
the back portion of the sentence that
says who's not been admitted so you take
an alien and then you you modify it to
say specified alien and you're
specifying that they have not been
admitted into the United States so I
think that's the they're stumbling
around you know the Goda ways the
illegal immigrants all the normal Al
language that many of us uh use when
we're talking to one another trying to
find a legal way of saying that but I
think what they're trying to say is we
don't know we don't want to House people
uh that are not here in a proper legal
status and there's lots of proper legal
statuses but it looks like they're
trying to find one where there is an
absence of legal status so I think we
got to get the bill sponsor in here
represent
priest thank you Mr chairman again uh
I'm just going to walk through a
scenario um which I think why this bill
is here um I have not spoken with this
sponsor um but it's it's seems like it's
a kind of relating to an emergency a
short-term
disaster um and you know short-term
disasters are defined here by you know
flood fire hurricane
tornado um high water earthquake
snowstorm all of these have been part of
New
Hampshire's history in the past and when
this happens to a large area and a large
group of people are affected they
usually direct them to the um schools
because that's where schools have
generators and hot water and facilities
for a shortterm basis and they even
Define this not to exceed 72 hours so
represent priest my question is this I I
had a question about your question
though if you look if you look at uh
line eight and nine it it seems to me
like it says it does not include
short-term emergency shelter so every
point that you just made was beautifully
made made and I agree with it but I
don't know that it's applicable to this
discussion so this is my question
because it is kind of confusing why they
Define this when it's for longer
durations well because they don't want I
I'm guessing because we don't have the
sponsor here but what I think they're
trying to do is to say like in the
hotels in in uh Manhattan in New York
City that have been basically almost
permanently turned over to house
migrants that what they're trying to do
is if there's a longer term shelter
requirement uh beyond beyond what they
call a short-term emergency that the
schools aren't to be used for people who
are here without legal authorization but
but if the dis if you know if there is a
disaster can they use them for shelter
for the residents Beyond 72
hours I don't know let's get the sponsor
in uh any other question Mr chair I
think it would be also good to have
someone legal here to see if if we're
going
against yeah you know but the other
thing is I keep getting chastised in the
past years of trying to take on policy
the policy has been we're just dealing
with we're just supposed to be dealing
with the fiscal and understanding the
fiscal note so I I I I think we should
entertain all the questions that may
impact our interpretation of the fiscal
note but I don't I want to be careful
not to revisit the policy too
strenuously representative
walner all right so I interrupted you
did you want to continue your question
no you you basically um
clarified uh the question that I had I
because I because I see in the law the
the ability to interpret it to say I
don't care who you are if if there's an
emergency you can do emergency shelter
of anyone but if you're beyond an
emergency Sheltering then then the
there's a it seems like there's a
Prohibition on people not here legally
from using the
schools that's correct but but that is
my conjecture based on a lot of
conjecture representative seaworth thank
you uh Mr chairman I and I would agree
with your conjecture and I I think I'm
not saying we shouldn't talk to the
sponsor but we can also read the plain
language of the bill that passed the
house I would agree with your
interpretation on line of line six or of
line eight uh I would also read the
plain language of line six which says
that all we're talking about here is
emergency Selter housing provided
exclusively to specified
aliens um so
again we can speculate well what if this
means all kinds of things that aren't
written here but I find the language
pretty specific when I read the bill and
so it frustrates me to say well what if
that doesn't mean exclusively what if
they really mean everybody in a town who
who shows up for emergency shelter well
then obviously to me it wouldn't be
those exclusively provided to specified
aliens all right so
than so representative priest you look
like you want to say
more I representative n vono yeah I want
to come I want to come back to the risk
analysis or risk assessment on the
financial end of this H have have we
ever lost complete funding for a program
for similar kinds of
reasons I don't know I think this was
provided based on would we be out of
compliance with the objective of the
funding so may I so as a followup to
that so typically you'd have some period
of time when you could you know um I'm
trying to get my head around is the
worst case scenario uh which would would
mean losing all of the funding because
of uh
some technical violation of the uh of of
the contracts or the policy and
typically that you know there'd be a
interim case where somebody would say we
think you're you're doing something
that's inv violation of the contract but
the worst case seems like it would throw
the baby out with the bathwater uh from
the standpoint of of at least uh
directionally for the bulk of the people
involved be
providing uh the spec specified services
so I I think I come back to what
chairman Edwards was asking was that
doesn't seem the worst case doesn't seem
like even close to a a most likely case
and so when you when you go to look at
the risk analysis you say Okay U 100%
loss is on one end of the spectrum and
the best case is it's a it's a waiver
situation where they say well
technically you're you're in violation
of the of the letter of it but we'll
wave it because the greater good is
providing uh the services to the bulk of
the people is that is that a
fair assessment again I'm not sure we
can make I can make an assumption about
whether or not the federal funding would
be at risk it was our analysis was that
the risk was indeterminable and the
range that we provided you is our
current award so again it's not we don't
have an amount that that outside of this
is the award and that the bill as
written in our interpretation would be
in direct conflict with Federal guidance
on providing shelter um and or in
conflict with Federal funding and Grant
obligations as they're written today so
then we gave the en the entirety of the
awards under both places for your
consideration but with the caveat that
it just may be an impact and that we're
not suggesting it would be the full
amount but we're just making sure you
have the all of the information that we
have and then everything else would be
some guess work right I understand that
so that's kind of an extreme uh at the
extreme end of what could happen but but
the most well I don't want to say the
most likely but there are um ranging all
the way from as I said a case where
nothing happens and you get a waiver
because some small piece of the language
was technically in violation uh to
something you know greater or lesser
than the uh zero case or the full full
loss of funding case but I I'm trying to
remember from my own uh I'm not sure
I've ever seen any kind of a scenario
where uh uh full funding was totally uh
withdrawn on a program unless that
unless you have an example of that I
don't have an example of that I know
that in the way that the current bill is
written includes those who are here
lawfully and therefore would also be a a
federal civil rights violation so
there's multiple kind of layers to the
way it's defined today that would be um
concerning to this this funding source
but if there's some amount of clarity
that is offered within the bill then we
would go back and rework that
analysis okay okay real good anybody
else for this witness thank you so very
much I'm sure we will have further
questions perhaps especially when this
bill will have another work session
scheduled so we'd welcome you back at
that point Thank you absolutely at this
point I want to direct your attention
you know when we last met on this bill I
came in at the tail end there and I
asked Mr Ripple to please provide the
precise accounting units that were
referenced and referred to in this bill
which he did so if you look at your
emails at precisely 12:12 p.m.
today he sent to all of us the exact
units we were looking for so there are
two I know we're getting ahead of
ourselves because we will have plenty of
time to go through all of the lines
however uh the two here are Health and
Human Services naturally the
Commissioner's Office Behavioral Health
and then we get into the office of the
commissioner and homeless and housing Mr
Ripple do you want to just briefly give
any remark with regards to these two
lines and what they are typically or
have been used for thank you um actually
so I would need to do a little a quick
bit of research in order to give you a
summary U I don't have that off the top
of my head but I can send to you if it's
helpful the uh definitions for these
accounting units that have been in past
budget materials provided to the
committee great I noticed that they're
General funds both of them and uh what
may be helpful is if anything in the
past has been used for reimbursement to
house those who are Without
Shelter okay anything further related to
the email sented precisely 122 p.m.
today regarding the two accounting units
in
question very good all right
procedurally Mr Ripple if we could we're
going to schedule a full Finance hearing
on non gerain amendment number 2025
H then thereafter we will schedule yet
another work session on House Bill 71
to take up that amendment that had been
publicly
heard everybody in agreement with
that okay any final words on this work
session for House Bill 71 and don't feel
bad if you don't get it in today you'll
have another
chance real good we're going to close it
work session House Bill 71 we're going
to reconvene at 2 o'cl to begin our
okay
e
all right it's uh it's a one minute P
two uh we're going division 3 is going
to come out of recess uh we're going to
begin a budget work session this is the
first time we're looking at numbers uh
it's the DHHS commissioner's overview
and then um subsequent to that we'll
walk through um the trailer bill that we
have so um with that I I know that the
commissioner is away today and I believe
Dr Hanah and Mr White will come in and
um now one of the things I'm I'm hoping
we're going to be able to do uh Mr White
is uh you I know we have uh the nice U
pretty documents here uh I'd like to be
able to uh have us Trace along and stick
our finger in the big nasty book along
with the nice Graphics so so can you
tell us what page and the big budget
binder we're going to be starting out
sure So today we're we're actually going
to be looking at numbers through a
couple of different lenses that are
aggregate there's some analyses that
that I worked on um after the governor's
budget was released to try to get better
perspective on uh how our budget is
funded in some of the complexities um
and then tomorrow we're going to be
going into the details of all of oom as
far as the operations Finance legal HR
facilities um we'll be going through
each of those detail by detail tomorrow
okay so today isn't about the the big
budget binder this is about your
separate analyses and the presentation
you have
correct yeah we've only had about one
full uh business day with the governor's
budget so we're working on those
presentations finalizing making sure all
the numbers are accurate for tomorrow
okay I could have saved myself a Heria
of bringing that but representative
walner thank you
um so one thing that I'm interested in
in every every is part of the budget is
uh your priority requests and I wondered
how we would be able to I know I can go
to the to the 3,000 page document that
was online for a while um but is there a
way we will be able to see that those by
division yes um and and I apologize I I
didn't introduce myself to start Nathan
white Chief Financial Officer with the
Department of Health and Human Services
um what we've done we've tried to
standardize our budget presentation
templates and at the back of each one
we've tried to to leave a section for
those prioritized needs so that um the
committee has an understanding of sort
of what what was funded and what was not
funded at the by the governor so you
have that record
there thank you that'll be just what I'm
looking for thanks Dr hen did you want
to introduce yourself as well sure um
good afternoon Marissa hen Deputy
Commissioner um and maybe I'll just go
right into the the content um first
wanted to thank you for the opportunity
over the last two weeks to come and do
some
non-numbers um conversations uh we hope
you found that helpful um and so I won't
belabor the introductory slides but it
seemed important to acknowledge kind of
the core reason we're here and why uh
this this funding matters um obviously
our our vision and Mission and values
hopefully came across in those
presentations and the fact that we do a
lot of stuff we do a lot of things um
from education and Service delivery to
health and safety protections and
Regulatory oversight um on slide four we
have sort of our best um attempt as we
talked with you uh a couple weeks about
ago at uh listing out our our core um
divisions and so um just want to uh also
acknowledge um you know how much you
heard and as a recap um you know you
heard from uh let's see we had Trish
chly here who talked about the
children's Behavioral Health System of
care which really crosses several of
these divisions in blue um we also heard
from uh we've heard from our Medicaid
leadership from um Anne Landry we heard
from um chrisan anello on developmental
disabilities long-term services and
supports we also had Meredith tus and um
Dave weeders here talking about
infrastructure and data and program
Integrity so I think what I want to
emphasize as we begin getting into to
the numbers is that our team is highly
integrated um when we speak pretty
regularly with other states they're
pretty amazed at how much goes on Under
One Roof we believe that's a real
strength of ours um the fact that we can
walk down the hallway and have a
conversation between division directors
to problem solve and to ensure that
we're operating in the most effective
but also very lean way possible another
element that supports that um
integration and that efficiency is
Illustrated on Slide Five which is
making sure we always know our true
north um our uh our road map sometimes
in other states called A business plan
is meant to help us keep our eye on what
is most important to the people we serve
um as well as how we invest in our own
people so they come and stay and do good
work and deliver the customer service
and the efficiency um that people should
expect um so a progress report on that
plan should be out any day um to help
get at some of the questions you've
asked around what's the return on
investment and the impact that we're
demonstrating through this work so
that's all I wanted to say by way of
introduction is thank you for having us
the last two weeks and for the
thoughtfulness of your questions um we
believe what we do is important um we
believe what we do is um vast in scope
but we also believe um like you we're
committed to doing it with great
efficiency and a commitment to being um
relatively easy to work with for the
consumer and for partners alike so
thanks for having us and excited to dive
into uh some numbers today with Nathan's
help excellent if you if you turn to the
next page um you will see a uh a couple
of circles there and the title is DHHS
budget complexity um for new members to
this committee that that have uh not
been through this process with uh with
dhs's budget there's just a couple of
things that I I want to touch on because
um DHHS is budget it is large it is
complex and it is integrated and um some
of the complexity allows us to uh to
essentially maximize the federal funds
that are available to us um however we
do have hundreds of well over a hundred
different Federal funding sources and
other funding sources and with some of
those funding sources there are specific
requirements that come with those and if
you um if you turn to the left there
you'll see a couple of bullets across
the left number one is cost allocation
so one thing that kind of sits behind
the scenes that the legislature isn't
really involved in on a day-to-day basis
is our Public Assistance cost allocation
plan and what that basically is it's a
200 I think we're at 260 page document
that we developed and what it does is it
defines the methodology that we use to
attribute certain activities to
different federal funds so certain
positions in our department are paid
with over a hundred different Federal
funding sources and we're able to do
that because we have this Fally approved
cost allocation plan we also use um we
use random moment studies and random
time studies to check on on certain
individuals and certain positions to
make sure what's the type of work that
you're doing okay we can claim fore for
that what's the type of work you're
doing okay we could claim Medicaid for
that so that we can maximize those
federal funds that are available um and
not use General funds and that's a
really important thing to understand but
one of the downsides to that I think
just from a budgetary perspective from
the seats that you're sitting in is if
you do unfund certain positions then
you're no longer to earn those federal
dollars in those positions and then I'm
kind of I'm kind of skipping ahead uh to
the second piece there maintenance of
effort so some of the federal grants
that we do receive require that the
state spend a certain level of General
funds towards that so if you have a
vacant position you're no you're no
longer going to spend General funds
towards a certain activity and you can't
apply that to your maintenance of effort
and that can come back to bite Us in
different ways as a state it may result
in penalties if you don't meet a
maintenance of effort it may result in
reduced federal funds for that year or
subsequent years and it's just important
that as we go through this when I if
there are questions or there or there
are requested actions those are just
some of the risks that I'm going to be
highlighting for this committee as we
move forward um we also we do have some
programs where we have matching funds
the Medicaid Program and Henry Litman is
going to be here on Friday um with his
team talking about the Medicaid Program
standard Medicaid we can for every you
know every dollar of General funds we
spend we get a $1 of federal but for the
uh the children's health insurance
program it's a
6535 um split for granted Advantage it's
9010 so there's there's different um
there's different Federal matching
levels depending on the
program and uh what you'll also see when
we start to dig in the budget into
specific class lines and accounting
units tomorrow we have I think at last
about 226 different accounting units um
so there is a tremendous amount of
detail in there I'm going to go over a
couple of the high the highest generally
funded accounting units today um on the
right there that that you've seen this
before that is our sort of visual
demonstration to show you the interplay
of of how we budget versus what actually
happens and how we cost allocate those
dollars so if you turn to the next page
um what I've tried to do here is show
the committee where the governor's
budget stands as it compares to the
current bium and the summary file that
you'll see in the governor's operating
budget and and I um I can direct you to
that if you are so inclined if you have
the governor's operating budget in front
of you it is on page
um on page
1,64 and and the comparisons that you
see in the governor's budget are the
state fiscal year 2024 actual expense
the state fiscal year 2025 adjusted
authorized and then the governor's
recommended budget and the actual
expense doesn't show what the budget was
it shows you this is what we actually
spent the adjusted authorized that shows
you any carry forward from the prior
year uh any new legislative activities
any fiscal acceptant expends those are
all showing up in that adjusted
authorized so sometimes the adjust that
authorized can actually be above what
the actual budget number is and so what
I've tried to laid out in front of you
here on slide seven is a comparison of
the operating budget there in the first
slide where you have House Bill one from
the current uh by name for
2425 with the 99.5 million and the just
over a billion dollars ear in 25 to the
governor's recommended budget that has
1.1 billion and 1.14 billion in state
fiscal years 26 and 27 now what wasn't
included in house bill one was all of
the hb2
Appropriations um which totaled U north
of $240 million and I'm trying to kind
of lay that out here and then another
consideration here and these are General
funds only by the way what what I've
also laid out here is the additional uh
General general fund Appropriations that
came through legislation from State
fiscal year 27 or excuse me State fiscal
year 25 so that when you're looking at
at where we are currently in the
governor operating budget compared to
the effective or one way of looking at
the effective operating budget for 24
and 25 you will see a net reduction and
as we present for the various division
areas we're going to be going through
what are the reductions and what do
those represent um so that you have U an
understanding of uh of the current
budget that we are looking at so moving
on to to page eight um what I've done
here is I have identify the major some
of the major areas primarily by division
and what you see there that the bar
represents the total funds over the
entire banum and Medicaid there on the
far left you'll see is about 2.6 billion
doar of total funds the blue represents
the general fund portion um of of of
that budget uh for the
bium and uh again on Friday we're going
to go into the details on that that to
understand okay in addition to the
general funding sources what are the
other funding sources and what does that
really mean the division for long-term
supports um and services the Bureau of
adult and aging um that that is the area
where we'll be talking about the county
cap so while there is $238 million of
General funds there there's also in this
bium I think around $267 $268 million of
money being contributed by the count
ities towards the CFI program and
Nursing Facility uh payments for
Medicaid eligible individuals the uh
dtss the developmental Services uh the
governor made reference to this I
believe in her um in her in her budget
address uh that's that's the number
relative to the billion dollars towards
uh DD Services over the course of the
banum um that's where you'll find those
numbers and in in those areas we have
matching funds uh primarily Medicaid
matching dollars that are available to
us that that's that's part of the reason
why you're seeing a much higher uh
Federal fund and other fund rate there
but when you move to the division for
children youth and families we do have
four e dollar available we do have some
tanif that we can use in certain
circumstances but um for the most part
uh that that function and that
responsibility falls to the state which
is why you're going to see a higher
general fund portion there um it's a
similar case in the division for
Behavioral Health as well and the and
the division of economic stability uh
the commissioner's office this is what
we're going to be covering tomorrow as
you see comparatively it's a relatively
small um piece of our budget but that's
where some of the core critical services
and functions um are provided relative
to uh legal facilities HR Administration
Finance accounts payable AR um and those
things that you need to make things
happen on a day-to-day basis um Public
Health you'll see it's $49 million of
General funds it's a relatively small
portion compared to the the federal
funds that we do receive that that is an
accounting area that um we have I think
close to if not above a 100 different
accounting units because we have so many
different small Federal awards that we
manage that come through that area and
then finally New Hampshire hospital and
Glencliff I combine those for for the
purposes here the the green you see
there um those are those are generally
speaking uh that is our other Revenue so
that's the revenue that we receive
through either um Medicaid Billings or
third party insurance that we're able to
collect there to offset the operations
at the 247 facilities so again what I'm
trying to do here with this slide and
then the upcoming slides is to give the
committee like a different perspective
because once you kind of dive down into
the single accounting units I think it's
easy to get lost there but but I'm
trying to provide a general overview in
cont context of sort of where the money
is at and and how the how the services
that that we've been discussing over the
past two weeks sort of fit into larger
budget
scheme on the next page what I've done
here is I've put together the top 15
generally funded accounts and on this
slide you you will see in 15 accounts of
HHS it it approximates about 77% of all
of the general funds and at the top
there the uh 7100 the DD Services
account uh represents a significant
portion Medicaid that's our standard
Medicaid line the
7948 uh as well the waiver payments to
County participation um that that's
that's also a significant general fund
account State phas down is something
that we're going to talk about it's a
requirement that we pay the federal
government uh a portion of funds back
this started uh probably 20 years ago or
more um where for individuals that are
Medicare and Medicaid dual eligible we
actually have to make payments back to
the federal government uh in those cases
and uh Child and Family Services that's
a that's a large accounting line within
DCF uh that represents the residential
service costs that the state pays for uh
on a on a regular basis and uh this
committee did add some additional funds
to that line last time to meet to meet
the needs uh of the children there the C
the Community Mental Health program
support um and and it kind of goes down
from there but the reason that I just
wanted to kind of provide this
information to the committee in advance
of getting into the numbers is so that
to kind of trigger uh your questions so
if you do have questions please reach
out in advance of each of these specific
presentations um but again just trying
to tr trying to provide a different
insight into into some of the accounting
units that we do have next up on the
subsequent slide is Staffing
so overall um the Staffing was
relatively stagnant however there were a
few pieces of legislation from this past
session that did uh that did establish
new positions um you'll see those in
DCF and that was one of the major
changes that we did see one thing that
that I would um certainly put out there
for the committee to consider um the
Hamstead hospital and resid treatment
facility we have had some recent changes
here uh through the budget so some of
you probably saw that GNC several weeks
ago um approved and we recently closed
on uh a an agreement with Dartmouth
where they will take over leasing uh the
facility and they will be running the
operations of the hospital uh we were
previously looking at a little over $4
million of General funds necessary for
the B for the state to continue um to
continue operating that now what we'll
actually see in this bium is we'll see a
net positive impact Dartmouth will be
paying the state um in in slightly less
than $1.3 million each year for lease
revenue and there is a subsequent there
is a bill that uh and I don't recall the
number off the top of my head there is a
bill currently that would establish a
dedicated fund to receive that revenue
and the reason that that that bill is
going forward is because the agreement
that the State signed with Dartmouth it
requires that the state pay up to $3
million in capital uh in in matching
Capital funds so if Dartmouth spends a
dollar then we have to spend a dollar
the advantage there is that Dartmouth
will be investing Capital dollars into
the state-owned facility but we just
need to match over the next 7 years up
to $3 million so I can certainly get the
committee the number for that
legislation
it's uhb sb18 um
yes I think we have a question
representative wner yes thank
you
so I looked at the Hamstead page in the
budget and I noticed that you know you
dropped down to zero yes but we will be
purchasing services from Dartmouth for
those children that are Medicaid
eligible is that correct
purchasing
service wait c c can can you clarify are
are are you thinking that we will be
paying Dartmouth directly or through the
Medicaid budget through the Medicaid
budget yes yes yes through the Medicaid
budget yes if they chip or standard
Medicaid eligible so though that we
don't have an expense any longer in
Hamstead hospital I mean we are still we
are still liable to pay for the Services
provided those children so it will come
through the Medicaid budget when we get
to the Medicaid budget will you be sure
to point that out because that would be
an increase in the budget for Medicaid
correct um no I I don't think so because
those individuals would would have
already been within the Medicaid budget
we were still claiming I mean we'd still
be getting Medicaid dollars for those
individuals the reductions that we saw
in the Hamstead budget um it was
primarily related to the operational
cost so it went through a couple
iterations where initially we had a
contractor providing all the clinical
and direct care and then we moved into
state employees for a period of time um
and and those were many of the primary
drivers of those costs but I can talk to
Henry in advance of that to see if we
can isolate something for you there yeah
I mean the model has changed so
previously um Hamstead hospital had a
finance office that was essentially
getting reim reimbursed reimbursement
through Medicaid as well as other
sources other uh payers insurers
Commercial Insurance
Etc um but so that that shouldn't given
the commitment to the underserved and to
low-income kids and families that are
required under the lease and the joint
operating committee we don't we expect
the number of um youth uh on Medicaid to
to stay the same or increase and so now
it's Dartmouth that is financially
carrying the responsibility for
reimbursement and risk so I don't I
don't see it changing if anything uh it
might even go down given some of the
generosity of those benefits as a state
hospital but um but your point is well
takeen okay
thank represented stream um just quick
follow up on that does that mean then
where we would see the change by uh
having Hamstead not part of um our
budget here is that the revenues
somewhere will be decreased since we're
not collect
true Hamstead we're not collecting from
managed care and so
on yes so so Hamstead was collecting
revenues um they were relatively small
amount I think for this year last I had
checked it was about $6 million but when
we were looking at operating costs north
of $20
million um it there were certainly
challenges relative to the sort of
long-term viability and so when we were
looking at the you know the what is the
net benefit as far as General funds Go I
mean we were really honing in on what
what are the general funds that would be
needed to continue operating there and
they were looking to be over $40 million
for the
bium
yeah I we we got to Staffing right the
that page I don't see a page number on
it
but it looks like the agency request for
Staffing went up by 12 from the the
governor's budget so the agency requests
this represents the positions that were
included in the efficiency budget um we
had a number of prioritized needs
requests to address the the legislation
that passed in state fiscal year 20 uh
24 and the reason that we had
prioritized needs requests for those
positions is because initially when we
put the go put the budget together
together the instructions were to not
have any new positions so we had to set
those positions aside that were
established via the 24 legislation and
put those in as prioritized needs so the
agency request again is the efficiency
budget um s SP 417 s SP
463 uh I think it was
1573 if I remember correctly I may not
um all all basically either established
SP 463 as well um either establish new
positions via legislation or would
require new position to implement and so
only a portion of what we had requested
was added to the governor's
budget all right well well thank you for
that I um I I do specifically want to
look at that list um and I'm I'm
particularly curious about the
DCF prioritized needs I I I I was
involved in uh a significant DCF Bill
looking at out of state uh inspections
all last year and I lost track of what
happened to it at the end of the term so
so I I would like to see where we ended
up um and then I
thought that the governor's request was
um based on giving you a number of 400
they looked at 450 vacancies and said
you could fill 400 and or excuse me 50
of and they held back 400 where where do
I see that number yep so um we had 394
positions that were unfunded during the
governor's phase those positions were
unfunded across dozens of different
accounting units um so you're not going
to see those show up in one individual
spot one thing that I was doing before I
came here Was preparing for tomorrow so
that as we go through different
accounting units I can say there's three
unfunded here there's three unfunded
here um to try to give you that
information we're also working and and
this is part of the challenge of of only
having about a business day or so we're
also working on um finalizing a
crosswalk so that as we go through the
budget you will see certain accounting
units have positions increase and
certain accounting units decrease we're
working on a crosswalk that we can
provide to you to address all those
questions because there are a lot of
different moving pieces that we have had
over the the current bium just to
address operating business needs so I
I'll get that prepped for you as well so
so the at the end result this staffing
change
so it's subject to change if the house
make changes what the governor's budget
did not do was it did not abolish
positions it unfunded the positions so
the positions still exist but what
you'll see show up in in the governor's
operating budget is you won't see that
full-time authorized or unclassified
line increase in numerically but you
will see a decrease in the class 10 the
salary or the class 12 the salary for
unclassified positions and the class 60
benefits you will see the decrease there
that's where the savings will be
generated okay so the first time second
time we run into that example i' I'd
appreciate a a a going over it in detail
so I know how to interpret the future
lines of course all right thank
representative tki I just want a
clarification on the um Staffing at
Hamstead so the 27 that are there are
you saying that that's going to zero out
or is that 27 remaining that the state
has so this this is probably an issue
that we'll we'll want to discuss um
because the because those positions
there have been
unfunded what we have done uh prior to
what we were doing prior to the close
was were working with um the individuals
that were there some many of them were
offered jobs with Dartmouth many of them
took those and then we transfer the
other individuals to other places within
the department um but what what I
suspect this committee would look to do
is to reduce that full-time authorized
count of 27 and so we would just want to
work with you to make sure that if we
are going to go down that route we
abolish positions that are vacant and
not positions that have someone in them
today and filled
okay thank you um all right any other
other questions do you want to continue
absolutely um if you turn to the next
page slide 11 and I apologize I I think
what happened maybe why one of the
number why the numbers were written over
was because I probably pasted an image
over that so that's my fault and my uh
PowerPoint
deficiencies um but on page 11 uh what
I've done here is I've pulled a couple
reports from the governor's uh budget
and I've looked at the the class 10 the
salary line for uh full-time authorized
positions the class 12 which is the
salary line for unclassified positions
class class 50 which is part-time
positions and class 59 which is
part-time temporary positions as well as
the uh salary and benefits to to um
demonstrate sort of what portion of our
budget is represented by Personnel what
you'll see there is slightly less than
11% is currently Personnel we and I'm
still working on the final numbers but
basically by unfund the 394 it's it's
effectively around 2526 million of a
general fund reduction over the banum um
to our Personnel
costs is is it is it the case though
that the use of contracts basically uh
is another way to effectively augment
Personnel so at Glen Cliffe and New
Hampshire hospital we do use contracted
agency staff to fill uh staffing needs
when we have them what we generally find
though is contracted staff are
significantly more expensive uh for the
operations of a 247 facility um so we we
try to maximize and retain staff
internally um in the state positions
because we're going to probably end up
paying a lot more if we're going to be
contracting that out yes sir I see all
of that I'm I'm just trying to
understand this ISS Personnel costs and
you just listed the the four categories
of permanent full and and so so we're
also having Personnel costs that are out
in the contract world that are not on
this slide correct I apologize I I
misunderstood yes in addition to this we
also have contracted staff in class 102
103 and that should be it okay and and
then do we have an overview of that um
the the Personnel costs associated with
contracted Services is
there so um when we were when we are
going to talk about the um the YDC
budget and the New Hampshire hospital
budget and the Glen Cliff home budget I
was planning on addressing that at that
point if that works for the committee
that that's probably 80% of our
contracted uh Personnel but but it
doesn't include things like it or public
health or so there would still be some
Miss components are those other
components not significant in your view
um I I think when um when when Ernie uh
Jillian and and Dave weers come to
present on the Bureau of Information
Services budget tomorrow we're going to
talk a little bit about that because
that that is a critical service that um
our Information Services team utilizes
right all right so again I'm just trying
to make sure I understand what's in the
slides what and what's not in the slide
and what's not in the slide are the
Personnel costs that are carried by
contract correct all
right
okay so on the next page again this is
this is a quick overview of what what is
to come in the coming days and weeks um
I'm so sorry I I've been meaning to ask
you this and and it's going to slip my
mind again if I don't and and since we
have contracted personnel and uh the
governor essentially imposed um I I
think a a a salary freeze for the this
budget I believe that's part of this W
was there a similar salary freeze for
contracted service support like the the
the project managers for it and the
epidemiologists or U UNH did we do did
the contractors pay pay the same freeze
prices our
employees so uh the governor via an
executive order implemented a hiring
freeze so right now um well we we we do
have the authority to move forward with
hiring Direct Care positions um we do
need to receive approval from the
governor's office for posting any other
positions so that's sort of how it
effectively hits us today I use freeze
wrong I'm I'm sorry you're answering a
good question but it's not the one I
asked and it's my fault uh what I'm what
I believe is in this budget is no coal
for employees we didn't we didn't
increase the the the the hourly pay
correct okay so so that that's embedded
in the Personnel cost you're going to
show us in the budget so my question is
did we do something similar with
contracted Personnel did or did the
contracted Personnel uh end up getting
colas because they have contract writers
and Provisions where the let's say you
take an it consultant at $120 an hour
are they going to be getting $150 an
hour or did we uh do anything to freeze
those that pay so there there was not
anything uh globally done relative to
contractor pay I think what what is sort
of a unique issue when you're budgeting
you may have a contract over here that
is good for you've agreed to the terms
for 1 2 3 4 5 years potentially um some
of the contracted staff that we do use
um they're Statewide contracts that are
administered by the Department
administrative services and we go for
through a request for qualifications
process to kind of add on to those or
tack onto those to be able to take
advantage um of the Statewide uh
resources
but in in dhs's budget there was not a
comprehensive reduction to the rates or
anything of that nature that we are
paying our contractors no okay so just
so so you know where I'm going with my
concern on that is employees will will
be rightly bothered if they don't get
colas uh or colas that keep up with
inflation or whatever we do with the
colas meanwhile it it feels like because
of the length of these other contracts
that uh there may be payroll or salary
increases that contractors are getting
that our own employees don't and I just
I I just want to be able to understand
what what we're doing and what the
magnitude of of all of that is so that
when we get the questions I'm able to
answer them um and I I you probably
haven't done uh because you've had so
much to do but you probably haven't done
an analysis of all the contracts for
which we pay effectively for contract
service support um that have salary
increases is embedded in them and you
don't know what the cumulative effect of
those salary increases are against all
900 of your contracts that's my guess
yeah and and we
also every contract looks a little
different if you've seen one you've seen
one contract because some of our
contracts are rate based some are
deliverable based some are cost
reimbursement but they may have indirect
costs in there and you can't necessarily
get insight into I mean you have Insight
but you know there's limitations on what
that pays for for um and gen and often
times what we do what we do see is when
we do budget we Flatline many of those
contracts year over-ear and you I mean
ask the provider community that that we
talked to I mean that's one of the
challenges that they have is that they
don't consistently see those increases
and so um I mean in our prioritized need
we did include a number of um rate
increases that we're going to be
touching on as we move forward uh and
and most of those at least the initial
phase there was not sufficient funds to
cover those but I I think it's a um I
will keep that in mind representative
Edwards as we prepare our budgets and
try to highlight that uh as as we go
into each of those class lines get into
the detail to try to address that
question for you okay um and I know
that's a lot of extra work that I don't
think I've seen in the previous two
budgets and so I respect the the the
workload associated with that I I do um
and if nothing else I'd like to
understand the magnitude of the issue
and um and I'd like you to think about
if there's any way that we can go to our
contractors and ask them uh essentially
to
voluntarily uh amend their contracts to
salaries it's crazy I know but that's
I'd like to be able to talk about that
okay all right thank
you okay okay so um as I was saying on
on slide 12 uh we this is a sort of a
quick preview of uh Coming Attractions
here so tomorrow we'll be covering the
office of the commissioner
operations uh on Friday we'll be digging
into the division of Medicaid services
budget if there are any specific
questions in advance of that please let
me know so we can work those into the
presentation um the subsequent Wednesday
uh Marie Nunan will be presenting on the
division for uh
children youth and families and then the
next day Kya Fox will be Divi presenting
on the division for Behavioral Health
the subsequent week uh Karen Hebert will
be here for the division of economic
stability and then Ian Watt on the
division of Public Health
Services and then finally uh during the
last week there uh the week of March
10th um Melissa Hardy with the division
of long-term support and services and
then Ellen Le Point will be here uh to
speak to New Hampshire Hospital in Glen
Cliff
home now this this is great I got I got
a couple loose items though okay one of
them is is attached to the department
when when will we get the presentation
on the prescription drug affordability
board that is something that I saw this
morning and need to address so that that
needs to be scheduled okay now C because
it's awkward this is the first formal
budget year that you guys are that you
have them attached to you I think for
the full thing are do you do you think
we should be working with them directly
or or should they come under the DHHS
and brella so they are admin so uh just
for awareness for all members of the
committee of the prescription drug
affordability board is administratively
attached to the department we have an
active mou with them where we provide
services and they uh reimburse us for
those Services related to HR
Administration legal and otherwise um I
think it would probably be best to have
them lead the discussion and then I can
join them for support more on the
technical end because we do provide that
on a day-to-day basis I think that would
work the best but for a coordination POS
point of view you the the department
should be involved yes please yes okay
so then the second one and I know this
is not yours this is more for Mr Ripple
uh what when when when are we going to
include the Veterans
Home the veterans home I believe is on
either the 11th whatever the last day is
that I've scheduled
presentations um okay yeah that's where
the nhhs and the Glen Cliff is yes yep
so the veterans home will be that
morning okay all right thank thank you
Mr White you can oh wait a second Mr
string or representative Stringham just
along those lines when when would the uh
DD budget be presented is that part of
uh divisional long-term supports and
services yes yeah on on the 10th and uh
yes go ahead okay so um I I what I
wanted to do here today we do have the
the draft of the house bill to that was
released on Friday if if you'd like to
go over it and I can highlight the HHS
Provisions if if that would work Mr
chair uh let let me I I looked at these
over the weekend um and I I think I
think some of them are just kind of um
redundant with previous years um and but
even some of the Redundant ones are
significant um yep so I I I don't know I
I don't I don't know a better way to do
it uh Mr White than to just I I can run
through them really quick and we can
talk about ones we want to have further
discussion I can get answers for
followup questions if Works let's start
okay yeah representative tki I just have
a quick question I don't know if this is
from probably from Mr rippel do we think
that this document is pretty well solid
will the draft we get whenever first
two-part question one um when would we
expect to get the official draft and two
is there a chance there could be
additional
items I think you could probably expect
to get it uh in about a week that's a
pretty typical time frame from when it's
uh been handed over from the governor's
office to OS I'm not sure if there will
be additional sections I've heard
anecdotally uh that there may be but I
can't I can neither confirm nor deny
that okay that helps thanks okay go go
ahead excellent so if you turn to page
uh 47 of 77 I just want to make sure
everybody's
there and there there aren't numbers
here so I'll do my best to kind of
narrate us through this um to start
there the Department of Health and Human
Services State grant and aid
what this provision does is this
appropriates $5 million each year of the
bium towards the state grant and aid
program and and that is a program that
is used for uh emergency shelter
Services there's uh I don't know off top
of my head I think around 1317 contracts
that the depart maybe more that the
department has with shelters around the
state historically this has been paid
for with 100% General funds uh however
uh individuals that are in the shelter
often have are either at risk of or may
have an opioid use disorder and this
provision directs those funds from the
opioid abatement trust fund towards this
purpose the next um can I ask a question
that go ahead um am I correct that the
the being able to spend the opioid
abatement trust fund money usually comes
from that committee or commission that
manages that and does the Governor have
the authority to spend it here in hb2 so
typically yes that that is where um
those funds are directed to I think
because you have the notwithstanding any
other law to the contrary that would
temporarily suspend that and allow for
the distribution of those funds from
that account thank you of course so I
have a question for representative
walner um with the way way cross I think
that's Sur name um Waypoint Waypoint
Waypoint uh do in their in their
resident programs or or their other
programs are they also dealing with uh
opioid issues or they dealing with uh
sober um
residents because because I'm I'm
wondering if we're looking for money for
Waypoint right so I'm just wondering if
if this $10 million a year is maybe part
of the solution for Waypoint and
I think I would want to confer with uh
Waypoint about that but I will do that
and let you know like I said I'm I'm
trying to find money and here's
ma'am do you anticipate that any of this
uh funding would go to
Waypoint
so I'm I'm no no um the these are the
state Granton Aid contracts and way
point uh the you shelter is not part of
that uh however the uh the governor's
budget did include $500,000 of General
funds each year for the Waypoint use
shelter contract that's an accounting
102 this is actually news so so I've
seen hb2 or not hb2 I've seen a bill 519
that has talked about the 500,000
but it's been my impression that that
500,000 was not in the governor's budget
and I think you just said it is I just
need to know where it is yes in in 3170
class
102 okay well that's that's good news
right did you know that no looking
for I think I just learned that okay all
right question um uh question represent
Stringham yeah can we have an accounting
of the um of the opioid fund as part of
the process the current balance yeah the
opio abatement trust fund sure along
with any uh other restrictions other
than how you uh approve it out as part
of this thank you yep
okay the next item next hp2 item at the
top of page 48 um this is the
perspective repeal regarding the
exemption from certain transfer
procedures extended so back in
2018 there was a provision of law that
was put into place with a delayed
effective uh date and what that would do
is it would take away the Department's
ability to move funds out of personnel
class lines um this is something that
the department regularly does to manage
um either the New Hampshire hospital 247
facilities the example we talked about
earlier was to in contracted staff lines
um to meet emerging emerging needs this
has been in place for a number of Bia
now um to to your point earlier as far
as being boiler Pate language an
alternative would certainly be to strike
the initial chapter law um but what we
had included in the agency budget was
recommending postponing it the next item
there the perspective repeal regarding
eligibility so so I have a question it's
probably the same question for both of
these um I I thought I I'm having a
flashback to last budget cycle and and I
thought what I what I what we wanted to
do last time was to take these regularly
recurring hb2 items and put them into a
place in the law to where we didn't have
to mess with them anymore and if we ever
changed our mind we could just change
that law instead of having to keep doing
hb2 does that sound familiar and and
what happened to that idea yes so we did
you we you um you did that with a couple
of items one of those items that is very
similar to this was the authority to
fill unfunded positions so that was
moved into permanent RSA I think it's
under RSA
126a um and so that has been codified in
statute and so you won't see that one
here this particular item was was not uh
was not resolved in the same manner it
was just
postponed okay this one and I'm guessing
the next one are they good candidates
for doing something
similar um given the history uh they
certainly could
be all right so um I think the new
people certainly need to hear the
details of what those are sure um so the
the next item the perspective repeal
regarding eligibility for services
extended um this comes from House Bill
191 laws of
2011 uh basically this has been extended
the effective date has been extended
over and over and over again because
what this would cause is it would cause
increase expenses at the community
mental health centers where they would
be required to provide services under
all conditions I think it's a little bit
more complicated than that and I'd like
ctio Fox to speak to this a little bit
about a little bit about this and the
history when we do the division for
Behavioral Health budget but this has
been delayed for over a decade now The
Graduate Medical medical education
payments uh has been suspended also I
think this might be the third by Ania um
where it may potentially be suspended
again this is the program out of the
Medicaid um division this would require
additional General funds if it were to
be
funded uh similarly the the just below
that there the suspension of
catastrophic Aid payments to hospitals
this is another provision that has been
suspended for another Bania same deal
where we would need additional General
funds to support that program If This
Were uh not suspended the next item
there this is the Medicaid to schools
program uh fiscal committee approval
supplemental
funding the fiscal excuse me the
Medicaid to schools program is a program
where the state share match the cost is
actually incurred by the the Lea the
local education um organization there
and the federal funds are budgeted
Within hhs's budget so it's it's cost
neutral to the state proper but it just
needs to be accounted for and the reason
that this exists is in the event um
local expenses exceed what we projected
it basically allows the department to
not go back through fiscal to accept the
additional federal funds into our budget
to meet that need in the event that
happens it has not happened uh yet um
but this this language was in the
current uh hb2
so so is this Medicaid to school item
um this this isn't going to show up in
hb1 it's this hb2 is the
entire no so so there there is a class
line within there is an accounting unit
within the okay yeah it's right there
I'm sorry so so that's where the money
will go how much is that
in the Medicaid to schools accounting
unit 7207 there's approximately $17
million of federal funds that are
budgeted today and that's all federal no
General it's 100% federal
funds okay and why why is it important
to bypass the fiscal committee that's
that's typically not done it's been done
with this program before but why why did
we make an exemption exception to having
this program bypass fiscal committee if
additional fed federal funds were made
available I I don't know the originating
history behind it uh I think one issue
is
that we have not been able to
necessarily project what the local um
educational units are going to incur
relative to their costs or what the
participation is going to be that makes
projecting it very difficult
I I think one one thing to consider is
generally speaking if if cost did if
they did start to increase rapidly at a
certain point of time the turnaround
time on fiscal committee and GNC
approval is about 6 weeks so if we get
to a point where we either failed to
project some change in expense we may
not have those funds immediately
available or wouldn't have the authority
immediately available um to to capture
those federal dollars so
I think it was in consideration of just
the process because we not only have to
go through fiscal we also have to go
through through GNC which is sometimes a
week and a half later right so so this
is one of those programs where I find
myself having to uh rationalize and
justify it to people that are friendly
with me and and I'm just uh I'll just
leave it for the committee that we we
may want to talk about uh requiring any
additional funds should there be any to
go through the fiscal committee which is
is a fairly standard thing and which may
give the house and the Senate more
visibility into the growth of this
program and the progress of the program
it it it seems to be a program of public
interest so so um so let's you'll help
me keep a note on that so that we can
come back and talk about that more all
right do you have any thoughts on that
okay all right I have a quick comment
yeah go ahead didn't we discuss this a
little bit when we were talking about
the services that are provided and we
were talking about physical therapy and
OT and yeah because we already did talk
about that that these are required by
federal law to be provided to students
yes well not to all students to special
education students I I I understand that
all the students that receive care under
here are um on IEPs and the IEPs lay out
what kind of services are to be provided
and then once that's done then it's up
to the program to deliver them is that
are we saying am I saying the same thing
as she is um I I I I think ju just kind
of going back to the language like the
the purpose of this is to essentially
ensure that there are no delays in those
payments for the services that are
provided that that that was a true
impetus behind behind this particular
provision so um if an individual does
qualify and the Medicaid services or the
services qualified for Medicaid and they
are delivered the um the local school
district they have to incur those costs
and we were just trying to make sure
that if they incur those costs the
federal matching dollars are immediately
available right so so if I if the
committee did get it in its head to
require it going to fiscal committee the
cleanest way to do that would just be to
eliminate this hb2
item uh yes if you eliminate this hb2
item we would need to go through fiscal
engine PNC all right that future
discussion thank you I wonder if it
might be helpful we can have director
Henry Litman on Friday speak to any
consequences of that it's a political
thing I I no I mean it's just how much
visibility does does the public want and
if there is growth in this particular
program and like I said it's it's been a
from my perspective it's been a program
that a lot of people have a tremendous
amount of anxiety about the ones that do
you know have anxiety have lot lot of
anxiety so I just I'm thinking through
the transparency part of it I I see the
the value and speed to funding I see
that benefit but there's a
tradeoff all right
sir from the standpoint of division two
looking into the education uh special ed
so if if a student has uh several
dollars spent on Medicaid to
schools and they include that in the
three and a half times when they start
to go to the catastrophic
Aid half of the money could be from this
but we won't know so it's not quite the
same thing as when we tell the school
districts you have to spend three and a
half times x before you can start asking
for help on special ed and they could be
crediting millions of dollars a came
from Medicaid to schools to say yes we
spent the money already so and every
time I ask for an accounting of how much
was in this 2 and a half 3 and a2x was
really Medicaid to school oh we can't
tell you
Hipp so it's it's difficult for us in
division two when we're trying to work
with how much money do we have to put in
do you have a comment Mr White I I don't
know if the extent to which you have
visibility into the issue you're
carrying in division two which I I
generally stay away from so not so much
best to keep my mouth shut yeah all
right uh okay so so go ahead now now I
think you're ready for uh DHS Division
of Medicaid services excellent
um so uh moving on to the appropriation
Wick Farmers Market nutrition program no
no you're skipping one on page
49 aren't we
still oh okay yes I apologize yep thank
you uh so this provision here this this
has been in uh hb2 for a couple of years
now what this allows uh the Medicaid
Program to do and and I know Henry wants
to speak to this this on Friday is this
at the end of the bium it allows the
Medicaid Program to carry those funds
forward into the next year this has been
done in in Prior Bania because uh a
Medicaid is a fairly volatile uh program
it is difficult to predict while we do
work with our actuaries actuaries are
you know we're basing our estimates uh
on the best information available um
this all this would allow us to carry
forward the funds at the end of the bium
into the next bium to fund the Medicaid
Program which would effectively reduce
the amount of General funds that would
be needed um in the next bium because
we'd be carrying any unspent funds
forward so would this be a decent
candidate for consideration of just
moving into uh RSA instead of repeating
it in hb2 my understanding is there are
certain states that have Provisions like
this in state law um but New Hampshire
to my knowledge has never had something
like this there but I think it's
certainly worth a conversation and I I
know Henry um and I definitely would
like to talk about it when we talk about
the Medicaid Program to just to give the
committee better understanding of of how
it works thank
you the next item is the wick Farmers
Market nutrition program so in hb2 of
the current bium there was an
appropriation made in the amount of
$600,000 for the wick Farmers Market
there were delays in getting that
program off the ground I believe there
were some rules that were required and
they had to go through the rule making
process and so all of those funds have
not been spent um this is a request to
carry those dollars forward to be able
to use in the for the program for the
coming bienia and I do not have the
exact amount of funds that are still
available but I will get that before we
conversation the next provision there
givs to the state so in currently in RSA
48 the department or excuse me there is
a provision in statute where the
Department of Corrections has the
authority to accept gifts and personal
property of less than $11,000 without
going through the GNC process um this
this here would align with the level
that the Department of Corrections has
for our 247
facilities um which includes New
Hampshire hospital Glen Cliff home uh
the the future uh Youth Development
Center when we drafted this hamstad
hospital was also included at that stage
so if it goes over 10,000 it goes it has
to go to GNC um if this were passed if
it went over 1,000 then it would have to
go through GNC so New Hampshire hospital
often has uh gifts so if someone brings
in say uh a I don't know um chairs or
books or a used gaming console uh shoes
uh any of these types of things or if
someone wants to give U Gifts or
presents for uh children at at youth at
YDC we have to go through the
administrative proc process of um GNC
approval this would essentially uh low
this this would increase that threshold
um so we may have fewer trips uh and
fewer uh requests to develop and submit
so anyone that wants to give significant
money to the YDC to have it named after
them uh that has to go to the GNC um I I
would assume so I've never seen that
happen normally this is much smaller
things like like uh you know shoes
clothing things of that nature games
th000 bucks isn't much I just I just if
there's a way to like increase that I I
I guess any increase triggers a
requirement to go to the GNC though this
would actually establish this at $1,000
it is not currently at $1,000 today no I
know it doesn't exist for you today I
want to both establish it for your
department but $1,000 is too little I
want you to be able to take tremendous
amounts more money than $1,000 CU that's
that's not even a bad broken car you
know um so so would you would you come
back when you when you're ready or maybe
you can just tell me now because I think
we would like to increase this gifting
amount without
triggering a bunch of extra
work okay uh yeah we can we we can take
that back and have a conversation
back I'm looking forward to the walner
Youth Development
Center
I represent no Ju Just a just a follow
up on that so you you have examples of
things that have been gifted right so
you can look to see what the range of
what you've had to go you know what the
range of those gifts in the past has
been and then maybe raise the limit to
the point where it you know
significantly cuts out trips to jnc
right and maybe that answers uh uh
representative Edwards it question it
doesn't my my my question is just how
big of a number can we take without it
triggering a lot of extra paperwork and
that's probably in statute somewhere not
not
history yeah there's some rules within
mop 150 that are set by the um set by
the executive Council that I think we
would just need to kind of go back and
take a look at and have further internal
conversations all right thank
you okay
um still on page 49 towards the bottom
there is a provision there relative to
unclassified positions being established
in SB 417 laws of 2024 two classified
attorney positions were established the
problem is that in chapter 79 laws of
2023 all of the DCF attorneys were
converted from classified to
unclassified
and so the 2024 Bill used sort of the
old Paradigm and what we're trying to do
here is is make it consistent so that
all the dcyf attorneys are unclassified
so this creates two unclassified
positions then the classified positions
if they were filled they'd have an
opportunity to move into those um and
then the classified positions would
subsequently be abolished so there would
be a no net increase to the total number
of positions it's um It's Complicated
cleanup I guess is the best way to put
it on page 50 the congregate housing
program this is this has been suspended
um in in Bia in past years this is
suspended for the current bayum because
it is not
funded the next provision under the
Department of Health Human Services
positions established Staffing amend RSA
126-a 9 this is a section uh these next
couple uh sections here we worked with
the Department of administrative
services to try to clean
up uh some of the appointing authority
language here the the Department
administrative Services based on my
conversation with them they they've
never been really happy with the way
that that the appointing authority for
the commissioner relative to
unclassified positions read so we we
work with them and collaboratively came
up with this language and we've included
this here for consideration it's it's
more technical in nature it doesn't
establish any new positions doesn't
authorize any funds
it it really tries to tie up the
language um and and make it clean so
that there are no interpretive
questions there's also a repeal of the
appointment of an unclassified Mental
Health Medical supervisor this goes back
years I could not find anyone still in
the department that remembers why this
was even in statute it doesn't establish
a position it basically told us to
appoint this position um to our best
knowledge this has since been um
satisfied via the the Dartmouth contract
that we have for Psychiatric Services
and so we were recommending that that be
struck from statute just to clean that
up uh following that you have the amend
RSA
12683 this this is the um also part of
the um the technical cleanup language
here uh sorry I'm just got lost here
there we go oh nope just kidding so
General Provisions at the about a Midway
down page 50 this is there's currently
legislation that's out there that would
establish or change the law to allow the
department to purchase brand named drugs
in the Medicaid Program currently
there's a restriction on that we only
purchase generic however included in the
governor's budget is a cost savings
where we would see an increase in rebate
Revenue by purchasing a higher brand it
make cost a little bit more to buy the
brand name drug but what we would see on
the back end is higher increase rebate
Revenue so there is a bill out there
that has the same language that you see
here and uh this would effectively allow
us to um it it's consistent with what is
in the budget and what you see there I I
can give you the exact number here
um it's
approximately uh $930,000 general fund
benefit State fiscal year 26 and almost
a $3 million benefit in state fiscal
year 27 by making this change to law so
so those numbers that you just gave us I
think I think part of what we got from
the governor was uh five sections that
were related to changes they were
recommending in
Medicaid
um this was in that sheet wasn't it the
the changing of the uh Pharmacy ordering
was that one of the five um I don't know
which document you're referring to but
go ahead I'm just saying I think I think
it is and I think this was a good idea
because we were always trying to save
money by ordering generics but now with
the rebate programs it's gotten more
complex and we can actually save money
leveraging the rebate program and yes so
so this is just smart management and and
this and and this just creates the
flexibility it doesn't create a mandate
it it gives the the flexibility to order
it that way yes yes to do the most cost-
effective thing possible okay all right
y so representative Daniels thank you if
I heard you correctly you're saying that
we would be getting the brand names
because it would give us more of a
reimbursement is that correct yes so we
we're able to earn rebate revenue on on
some of the prescriptions and by
purchasing might be more expensive
upfront but we would see the benefit on
the back side so what you see in the
budget is you see General funds decrease
by 930,000 you see other funds increase
by the equivalent
amount so would at the federal level
would we see an increase in price
because they're using brand name drugs
is as opposed to a decrease when they're
using
generics I mean are we just changing
from one one pocket to
another so I I I think it may be best to
have a more in-depth convers ation when
when Henry gets here and we can kind of
go into a little bit more of the details
around what what this looks like on a
daily basis CU they they have a they
their their pH the Medicaid pharmacist
team they look at this stuff on a daily
basis and probably get you a better
course I think the principle though is
is that they they let's say you take a
nice brand name X and it happens to have
a generic
what we've been saying is don't order
the the the brand name X go get the
generic because we think that's going to
save us money well what we figured out
is that we can actually order brand name
X but because there's a rebate program
associated with it the the the drug
price minus the rebate is cheaper than
it we ordered the generic and so this is
just an alternative way to where we're
netting savings is the goal of this
yeah my my question Mr chair is is it
costing us more at the federal level to
Litman okay um so moving on to the next
provision in the middle of page 51 in
hb2 the current bium an appropriation
was made in 2.8 million for a pilot
program um in in the DD service realm
and the SE were individuals that uh did
not qualify under the under the waiver
itself um I believe there's currently
eight individuals what this
appropriation does is allows us to carry
forward those unspent dollars to
continue providing services to
individuals that are currently in the
program who will be aging out during
this
bium and it's it's more of a one-time
thing to prevent those dollars from
lapsing and those services from ending
before those individuals uh potentially
qualify for waiver Services when they
age into
it the so the impact is no new money
we're going to be spending down the laps
and we're going to be graduating the
final eight without adding back more new
people in the future correct
okay the next provision here at the
bottom of page 51 so s SP 463 three
passed last session laws of
2024 and it had an effective date of
July 1 of
2025 that bill created um a pretty hefty
workload on the department I believe the
fiscal note had identified a need of 14
additional positions um we included
prioritized needs requests for those 14
additional positions um that that we
were that that was not included and so
what has been included here is a delayed
effective date for the subsequent bium
um given that those positions uh do not
exist and have no funding so in order to
effectuate the purposes of the bill um
there wouldn't be resources available to
do so so so who's done the biggest Deep
dive and who kind of owns this issue
with n DHHS the the director of DCF or
one of the associate Commissioners or
who who's kind of the person that if I
want to really dig through this who who
I should be talking to yes so associate
commissioner uh Trish Tilly and um DCF
director Marie Nunan can we see the
Marie Nunan n o NN yeah can assist you
with any questions you have on that one
so miss Tilly would you rather I go
through you or go straight to miss
Nunan all
you question so that effectively moves
it out of this by any is is that what
this is saying yeah okay but but there
are still what 12 other positions or
there's a bunch of positions still that
that aren't affected by this right
correct and and those those positions
were were formally established via the
legislation yeah all
right the next item is County cap which
and it it is just below uh the Canon
Mountain Tramway it's County
reimbursement of funds limitations on
payments and this this goes back to the
conversation that we had the week prior
around the um the funding methodology
that state employs for choices for
Independence and Nursing Facility
Medicaid payments and what this
provision does here is this amends RSA
16718 a and in that section of Statute
that is where the quote unquote County
cap is uh I.E the amount of um money
that the counties contribute towards the
CFI and Nursing Facility Medicaid waiver
payments and the adjustment here this
reflects the 2% maximum increase that's
allowable under statute uh for the banum
and this this is something that you'll
see in hb2 every year because that's
where this provision is typically
adjusted
so so is this showing up as other
Revenue somewhere in hb1 yep so in
accounting unit
2152 um you will see a number close to
this but different from this what you'll
see in that accounting unit is you will
see the county cap here minus the credit
that's also stipulated in RSA
678a which is $5 million default so what
you'll end up seeing there is an amount
of $5 million less than what you
actually see in statute because of that
credit so this will never ma this
generally speaking will not match the
accounting unit other fund Revenue line
so so the effect of that credit is it
actually effectively reduces the amount
the counties have to pay correct okay
and then you know that there's this
ongoing discussion about um the covid
era collection of either 22.3 million or
25 million depending on what the most
recent final number is yes
um one one way to potentially deal with
that would be to to what increase the
credit so that so that they would start
to get get that money back and it would
look like reduced revenues to
us that is certainly one way that you
could do that if you if you were to do
that what you would end up seeing in the
accounting unit is um let me see here so
currently the private local funds it's a
005 line on page 903 of the budget and
accounting unit 2152 shows up about 129
million and 132 million each year uh
what what you would end up seeing there
is is you would see the 129 minus 11 or
the 132 minus 11 but what you'd also
need to do is increase the general fund
contributions within that line so the
first year of the budget would go up to
about n almost 96 million in the second
year of the budget would be about uh
almost $18 $109
million um in in general fund so that
credit would me to be compensated by the
general funds right so so I think this
is a yes or no did did the did the
governor's budget include that
additional 22 or 25 million back to the
counties no the governor's budget did
not includ so we'd have to basically be
finding additional money to fund that uh
that re rebate or reimbursement correct
all
right good what else you got so that is
all of the current hb2 Provisions um
that are available today I do expect um
come Friday we may have some additional
hb2 Provisions to discuss relative to uh
Medicaid eligibility premiums and cost
sharing may may I ask you a couple
Strays sure they don't need to be
answered today but uh I'm I'm looking at
the the capital budget uh and there's uh
the Medica Medicaid expense modular
strategy um that's going to end up um
being around 33.7 million uh it's a it's
a it's it's not itemized or broken out
um but if you could get Mr weeders uh
when he comes in for it to to to break
out what's what's in that and and in
particular what I what I'd like to know
is what the uh contract service support
is so so like if we get this Capital
item approved does it come with its own
project managers wrapped in it or or do
we have to pay for the project managers
out of
operations so that that's just it's a
big it's a big thing um and then
modernize eligibility Services it's not
quite as big but I'd like to have Mr
weers just talk about it at a high level
with sort of the same similar thing as
what is the operational impact on on uh
it service support for
contractors sure okay that that that's
that's a future thing and then uh I I
had a a very nice Exchange with uh with
commissioner Landry uh today I think do
I call you commissioner I keep
forgetting all your titles Miss Landry
um we found uh you you know I've been a
a an Ardent supporter saying I don't
think the department uh does
Dei and um and we found on the UNH
website something titled uh NH office of
Health Equity and it's a it's got
several pages
and uh this uh is is is written by UNH I
guess but it's talking about the office
of Health Equity which I think belongs
to the department um and in the exchange
of emails I think I think Miss Landry um
said that this is an old dead program
and that this is not anything that's
going to happen in the future would you
would you you can sit at the end I think
this
is
90% good afternoon an Landry associate
commissioner yeah
um do you want me to address your so yes
I to our understanding that that that is
not a current offering of of the
department or the office of Health
Equity in fact um my guess is it it
might have been something that someone
in our department who no longer work
here was trained to do and maybe there
was a request but it's not a training um
internally or externally and it predates
our current director's time so I
appreciate you bringing that to our um
awareness I actually couldn't find it
myself when I Googled it or looked at
the UNH website it almost looks like
it's an internal document internal
website to UNH so we are doing our due
diligence and ensuring that all of any
any vendor um who lists any of our
training that we offer for the
Department are are current and up to
date so I I appreciate that
questions I'm that document appeared on
a UNH worksite I think or a
website and but it did uh show that it
was a
DHHS document so I'm I'm not
sure I'm not sure I understood what you
know I I was unaware that that document
existed and I you know I'm remiss to say
that but to that is not a current
offering of the Departments or of the
office of Health Equity in fact I
believe it predates um even maybe my
time overseeing the office of Health
Equity it's not clear but we do not
offer that training and we were unaware
that that was on a list on the UNH
website so we're doing our due diligence
and ensuring that any place offer that
shows our trainings that we offer it's
that it's up to dat and
current so you you'll get back to us
after you do the due diligence
or to ensure that it's been removed that
the current lists are all we we are in
the process of doing that we're they
Ruben reached out to them today to take
take down that list but we're also
looking at any um to making sure that
all of our trainings regardless of what
they are are up to date regardless of
the topic um because that was that was
an old document okay so so it's possible
at some point to get get a list of all
of the trainings oh sure yes sorry I
miss your question we can do that yes so
is that your request is that we get a
set a list of trainings that the
department provides just yeah I would
are you looking specifically for office
of Health Equity or are you looking
across the entire department what what's
what's I'm look across the entire
department um do you do you have a
comment on the workload effected yeah
that that may that may be a pretty hefty
load given that across all of our
divisions we're doing dozens if not
hundreds of trainings I think what I
heard your question asking was why there
was co-branding on that particular
document and wanting to be assured that
this is not a training that's provided
endorsed or paid for by DHHS which we
can assure you based on the work um
associate commissioner Landry did this
weekend there's no connection to DHHS
with that train and it predates all of
us does that does that address the
concern or are you actually looking for
more information around trainings from I
was looking for some additional
information without unnecessarily
increasing the workload but definitely
I'll would be interested in additional
information on on is there is there any
other department I mean because of the
naming people are concerned about office
of Health Equity but would there be any
other uh Department Public Health he or
or any other department that would be
worried about sort of this cultural
sensitivity kind of training that that
instead of asking for the entire
department we limit what we're looking
for I think yeah why don't we if it's
okay with you maybe let's huddle after
this with the associate Commissioners
and get right back to you with um a
suggested response that I think will
fulfill the request that would be
fantastic great thank thank you for
jumping on that that you got that
request over the weekend and here it is
the first week work day and you had a
great answer so so thank you for that of
course thank you um yeah so uh with that
I I do you think you're done with your
prepared remarks yes y okay anything
else you want to add not prepared uh no
not at this point okay are there any
other questions from the
committee I'm I'm not seeing any is is
there any public comment anyone uh in
the audience care to make a comment or a
statement of any
kind I'm not seeing any and as my custom
Mr Ripple what what are we doing next we
have a meeting tomorrow right we have a
meeting tomorrow at 10: a.m. and uh all
day is dedicated to the Commissioner's
Office budget okay and and then I I have
a a p personal comment for the committee
I I but because it's personal I'd like
to uh see if we can just adjourn and
I I think you can do that all right so